does your perspective change at all on
your confidence about
the nfl and you guys being able to have
a season safely and keeping everybody
healthy
my confidence hasn't changed at all um
i'm extremely uh obviously optimistic
but uh you know um
i i feel like we're gonna play i'm
confident that we're gonna play
you know and and it's
it's just it's unfortunate you know i
like i told my team last night you know
this virus
it holds no prejudices right it doesn't
it doesn't matter it can affect any one
of us
doug peterson eagles head coach covet 19
positive asymptomatic but per the rules
that the nfl and every other sport is
following when you are positive you are
removed from the population because you
can infect others and they can infect
others and eventually the virus lands on
someone that it can seriously sicken or
kill good news doug peterson is fine
uh he's very optimistic there's a lot of
optimism behind the scenes still that
football can work but you know chris hey
they're lucky that peterson is dealing
with this now because
training camp isn't really at a point
where
the head coach has anything to do when
it comes to coaching the players on the
field right but this is going to be
a constant possibility just like it is
for the players i mean you know injuries
always
are that vague thing that hovers over
football and you never know when
lightning is going to strike and take
out a key player
this thing
covers everyone
and you never know
when a head coach
is going to be removed
from the team
put in isolation
and unavailable to do his job for games
which
which adds an element to this that is
both fascinating yeah and terrifying
yeah no you're right it is i mean it i
think it is terrifying
i've had two different coaches tell me
that they were thinking about at some
point during training camp
it you know
pulling the cover 19 you know cord and
and basically going oh guys you know
emergency drill i got covered 19. i
can't coach today somebody else got to
be out here do the you know run the run
the practice run the 11 on 11 scrimmage
whatever it may be you know again we've
hit this a few times but i think this is
a very real possibility and it's
probably making a lot of coaches you
know not sleepless sleep well at night
but you know yeah it's different you're
right you never really think about
coaches oh what am i going to do to
replace this guy or man what if i lost
my offensive line coach you know these
are real issues that are stressing
coaches out this year and they're going
to have to think of a fail-safe plan in
case something does happen during week
four or week eight or whatever it may be
so you know at this time hey doug
peterson he's lucky gets it now he's you
know i don't mean he's lucky like you
know what i mean i'm just saying he's
lucky it's over with his team's gonna
get to deal with it and to your point at
least they're not on the field and
really practicing and going through a
lot of you know in-depth schematical
stuff quite yet to where all right you
can deal with the head coach being away
he'll watch in the zoom meetings and
he'll you know he'll add his two cents
here and there and that'll be fine so uh
but we'll see that's a scary situation
and i don't know how lucky he is chris
because we still don't know how long the
antibodies last yeah it might just be a
couple of months before
it wears off and you can get it again so
sean payton who had it and had symptoms
from it back in march
he may be in a point where he could get
it again and every coach every assistant
coach could get it at some point and it
reminded me as you were explaining it of
josh mccown's experience in tampa bay
several years ago when jeff tedford was
the offensive coordinator under lovey
smith
tedford ended up leaving with a heart
problem yeah that popped up just before
the season started and after the dust
settled on that season josh mccown
explained hey
you have a backup quarterback you have a
backup center you have a backup long
snapper you have a backup this back you
don't have a backup offensive
coordinator so if he's gone what do you
do and i think that same concern applies
to every coach and obviously the higher
that they are on the letterhead the
greater the damage can be done without
him there but that's the problem and
that's the risk and that's of all the
other things you got to be ready for you
got to be ready for that as well you got
to be prepared for the possibility that
the head coach the coordinators any
member of the staff
shut down and maybe multiple members of
the staff if they're not being as
extremely careful when they're
interacting with each other now chris
that leads to something that my
understanding is it came up yesterday on
your podcast i got in touch with the
league and i asked this question because
i had conversations with people in the
past about assistant coaches especially
some of the assistant coaches or head
coaches who are older yes who may have
had some health issues right who may not
feel comfortable going forward with
pro football this year in the pandemic
will they have opt-out rights and the
league's position
unlike with players or officials where
with the players we know what the rules
are for opting out with the officials
they're going to have something at some
point that gives them a window to opt
out for the coaches the league said
these are individual club matters yeah
meaning the league isn't going to create
any procedure any protocol any rule to
have consistency among the 32 franchises
to give coaches the opportunity to say
i'm taking this year off so the end
result is
some teams may allow it some teams may
not allow it some teams may give you an
open-ended opportunity to decide at any
time like baseball i'm leaving i'm
coming back i'm leaving i'm coming back
other teams may say you're in or you're
out and
as of right now we haven't seen what any
of the teams specifically are going to
do there's been no word of any head
coaches taking the year off
uh i vaguely recall somebody that was
thinking about it but it hasn't it
hasn't been anything like it is with the
players and we've had a bunch of players
who have walked away for coaches it's
just it's an afterthought it hasn't even
been raised right uh and and i think
some of these guys should be seriously
thinking about opting out giving their
age and giving their health history no i
think you know i do think there's
concern with certain coaches like you're
talking about throughout the coaching
community you know the first thing is
guys that coach in the nfl first off i
mean they're psychos they're lifers this
is what they do this is what they want
to do they they they're they'll they
can't even like you know fathom life at
home on the couch you know being that
kind of whatever dad whatever father
whatever el you know husband no they
they they love the grind they love being
around the action on sundays and doing
all those things so you couldn't get
some of these guys out of there no
matter what now you know as we went
through the the pandemic in the early
phases like this stuff came up a lot
with you know
different friends i had where they were
talking about man what about this coach
are they gonna is he really gonna want
to go back in the building and you know
first off is hey a lot of these head
coaches and and to make it a personal or
a individual team decision a lot of
these head coaches have hired guys that
yes they know they have history with of
course they like them that's why they
hired them and all that they know their
families and they also know the guys who
are older and have maybe some medical
risks here with the pandemic and the
current circumstances so with all that
knowledge you know and these head
coaches they're they're human beings
they don't want to get one of their
their their guys on their staff sick and
you know have a you know have them not
be able to be a father to their kids or
or grandfather or whatever it may be
they have human hearts and i think there
was a very real situation there and i
know there's a few cases where you know
coaches said
like hey don't come like you can coach
from home don't worry we'll be okay if
you want to do that to some
specific position coaches mike but you
know those coaches like we were like i
was just saying they're not going to
have it they're they're coming that's
what they want to do that's part of what
who they are in their makeup and their
dna so i i think the human element will
save the coaches here because it is a
fraternity in a lot of ways and the head
coaches do have personal relationships
with these people and don't want to see
anything bad happen to any of them
but it is kind of baked into who you are
as a coach and it's who you become with
all those hours and months and years of
grinding grind and grinding and this
mentality of i'm gonna die with my boots
on right this is a situation where you
could and this is a spot where you need
to take a step back and ask yourself is
this the right thing for me is this the
right thing for my family the problem is
if the team isn't setting up a formal
program that allows you to opt out it
just never even comes up yeah if if yeah
look at it this way
if the team's attitude is we're just not
gonna open that door we're gonna wait
for someone to come to us and raise it
there's a good chance no one's to raise
it that's why i think part of the
obligation for the owners out there
who regard their
employees as number one human beings and
number two extended members of the
family to have something
that is clear
and express
and specific
as to what they can do if they choose to
opt out if they're not comfortable that
and and maybe it's been glossed over
because all the focus has been working
out this deal with the union the players
are making a push the players are making
a stand remember the stream of tweets
from a couple of weeks ago that really
kick-started the process of working out
the deal between the league and the
union
maybe it's just been forgotten because
the coaches don't have a union this is
another example and i know that owners
out there are not going to like this
the coaches should have a union
yeah that's part of the psychology chris
that has these coaches not questioning
whether or not they should opt out sure
whether or not they even have the right
to opt out they have no rights their
rights are set forth in a contract that
has an arbitration clause that says in
it all disputes will be resolved not by
some third party that has no connection
to the teams or the individuals all
disputes are resolved
by the commissioner
who's the commissioner
going to resolve all disputes in favor
of typically
the individuals
or
the teams that collectively and
individually
hire and employ the commissioner so this
is an example where the coaches just
don't because they sign whatever they
have to sign because all they want to do
is coach yeah and i feel badly if there
are guys out there
who are carrying around this burden and
this concern every day and they know
there's nothing they can do about it
because there's really no way out and
they're not going to go ask for it if
it's not offered to them so we'll see
what happens yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports